we start this hour with the escalating
situation across the occupied West Bank
Israeli settlers have attacked another
Palestinian Village in Northern Ramallah
they set fire to homes cars and other
properties in the village of turmo Saya
there are reports of injuries this is
the latest round of violence after the
killing of four Israelis on Tuesday near
an illegal settlement Harry Fawcett is
that there is near the entrance of tour
musaya Village in Ramallah start with
What's Happening Now Harry and what
you're able to see
well yeah this this attack took place
earlier on Wednesday what we're hearing
is from people inside the village of
termosiah what they're telling us we're
also getting some information from the
Palestinian red crescent Society we
haven't been able to get in there
ourselves uh there is a police or an
Israeli forces checkpoint uh just near
the entrance there and when they spotted
our Palestinian license plates they
allowed us to go no further uh despite
the fact we're journalists they said
they couldn't care less and so that's
why we're here but what we are hearing
from inside is a pretty disturbing
picture that according to a couple of
sources from the village uh up to 200
Israeli settlers from a nearby
settlement attacked the village earlier
on Wednesday we've also had a slightly
contradictory statement from the head of
the local Council who puts that number
much lower at about 40 but nonetheless
that some of them were armed and they
came with fuel and sticks at least three
houses totally burned about 20 uh
damaged by fire and by rocks and and
damaged in other ways but in terms of
the injuries that's what is more
disturbing we're hearing from the
Palestinian red crescent that some 12
people were injured by live fire now
there are some suggestions that perhaps
some of the settlers themselves were
shooting those bullets
um there is also a confrontation after
the settlers left between Palestinian
residents and the Israeli forces who
came in shortly afterwards uh injuries
sustained as well by Rubber coated
bullets from tear gas as well and we
were hearing about a potential other
development I'm just going to talk to my
producer Aziza do we have any
confirmation
of potential fatalities we don't have
that confirmation yet but there are some
suggestions that some of those injuries
May well have have turned more serious
at least so this is a very major attack
people in this Village say they are used
to quite a lot of circular violence here
but they've never had an attack like
this in their experience yeah and we
understand it's a rapidly developing
situation of course Harry this is not
happening in a vacuum far from it
talk to us about the sharply escalating
cycle of violence over the last 24 36
hours alone
well yes I mean there's approximate uh
rapidly escalating cycle of violence and
there's one that is some months long all
within the context of course of the
wider conflict but yes uh early on
Tuesday or in the afternoon or Tuesday
rather there was a Palestinian shooting
attack at a petrol station just outside
another illegal settlement the
settlement of Ellie north of Ramallah in
that attack four Israelis were shot dead
four others were injured an Israeli man
exchanged bullets with one of the two
suspected uh one of the two attackers
one Palestinian man was left dead at the
scene another was then surrounded a taxi
he was driving in was surrounded by
Israeli forces north of Nablus later in
the early evening he was shot dead
inside that taxi and then since then
there has been this wave of secular
violence targeting Palestinians in
various areas up and down the West Bank
late on Tuesday night we saw a lot of
that concentrated around Nablus the very
consistent flashpoint of huwara but also
other villages in the area as well fires
were set dozens of people were injured
in those attacks we now have this
situation here as well and on top of
that there have been people massing
Israeli settlers and secular Setter
activists and Senior government figures
on the far right of this coalition
government who've been massing at a
place called eviatar a so-called under
Israeli terms illegal Outpost from which
people were rejected over many occasions
but most recently in 2021 there are now
very firm plans to re-establish that
settle that illegal Outpost into a
settlement in Israeli terms it's still
illegal under international law and so
there are there's a prospect potentially
of further confrontations between the
village of beta which is just under that
settlement again a very regular
Flashpoint and this this massing of
settler activists there one other point
from the Israeli side they're saying
that they are promoting the planning of
1 000 further new units at the
settlement of Ellie where this attack
took place they say that's in response
to what they call terrorism uh the uh
Palestinian executive committee of the
palace in the Palestine Liberation
Organization the Secretary General of
that committee he's saying that there is
organized terrorism coming from the
Israeli side
Harry Fawcett near the entrance of
turmusaya Village in the occupied West
Bank thank you for your reporting
Israel's far-right government has also
just approved the construction of a
thousand new units in the early illegal
settlement the site of Tuesday's attack
that Harry was telling us about Al
jazeera's Imran Khan is in West
Jerusalem with more on that Imran
well it came via a statement of
into office it said the decision was
reached by prime minister Benjamin
Netanyahu the defense minister yo of
gallant and the Finance Minister betadel
smartridge our response to Terror it
says is to strike it with force and to
build our country this a thousand new
settlement units within Ely is being
seen as a Act of defiance by the
Israelis in the face of what happened on
Tuesday this was announced on Wednesday
now oftentimes they do announce
settlements after an attack such as this
but right now things are very different
just a few days ago the process to
streamline settlements was actually put
forward and approved by the cabinet it
used to be a six phase process at any
point during those phases politicians
the International Community could raise
objections they simply got rid of that
and now bethesdale smotrich who's the
Finance Minister is now almost
completely in control of approving those
settlements so this will be a big
victory for him this is on top of 4 000
new settlements that will be discussed
on Wednesday that Drew International ire
particularly from the U.N Secretary
General Antonio Gutierrez who said that
these settlements are needed to stop now
Betsy's old small church has also been
calling for a large-scale operation in
the occupied West Bank comments have
been echoed by the national security
minister itamar Ben Giver they haven't
got that so maybe this is the compromise
but there's enormous amount of pressure
on prime minister Benjamin Netanyahu
from the far right of his coalition to
launch a major operation in the occupied
West Bank and his far-right Coalition
Partners have the trump card they say if
you don't do it we're simply going to
quit the Coalition and force new
elections Imran Khan in West Jerusalem
thank you very much and still